[Musique]
marina ans que bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle singer view on
aurait aimé un petit peu à voir votre
lecture et votre prisme de lecture sur
les interventions militaires dans le
monde et les relations internationales
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement quel parcours vous avez
bien sûr je suis actuellement prof à
l'université northwestern qui se situe à
chicago aux états unis est aussi
professeur invité à sciences po paris
je suis de l'originel monde mais j'ai
fait toutes mes études à l'extérieur
dallas mène je serais passée montre
hémicycle lisez en france à sciences po
paris notamment et ensuite je suis parti
aux états unis fait un doctorat de
princeton et après de preston je suis
donc allé arracher drago pour renseigner
les relations internationales là bas et
mon expertise c'est les relations
internationales mais notamment la
sécurité internationale et les
interventions militaires qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire dessus en ce
moment en europe en afrique que six
passes
tout d'abord
les entendre si les interventions
militaires c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui arrive très souvent
alors depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
il y avait plus ou moins 150
son intervention militaire multilatérale
là il ya toujours une distinction entre
elles et multilatérales et les les
interventions qu'ils ont juste ménée par
année terre comme par exemple la france
ou les etats-unis moi je suis notamment
experte des relations
internationales multilatérales adore je
m'intéresse aussi pour pour les
interventions qu'ils ont mené en
coalition mais là actuellement bien
entendu il ya des interventions ont peu
partout comment ça se passe le
financement par exemple de ces
interventions là c'est clair fait
transparent
parce que le public est au courant de
commencer financer les points il faut
savoir que pour n'importe quelle
coalition il n'ya jamais avec en sus une
convergence d'intérêts
alors si en bois par exemple 20 pays qui
participent dans l'opération de l'otan
en libye on peut plus ou moins assumée
que peut-être il ya deux trois pays qui
s'intéresse vraiment pour boucler
l'opération du tube bon pour la libye
c'était la france et l'angleterre 2 1 3e
le troisième a même cessé tout ça c'est
tout ça c'est financer tout ça bon
c'était une opération de l'otan alors
l'otan a pas de financement autonome
l'onu a
un budget qui ensuite finance
les enfants les soldats en gros
directement directement web en cash par
virement par contre il ya un
budget pour les opérations onusiennes et
ensuite chaque état chaque soldat qui
est envoyé par un état membre de l'onu
elle reçoit à peu près de 1300 dollars
par mois et ensuite le livre en bourse
aussi le ferait pour l'équipement par
exemple pour nous parce qu'elle
voitures hélicoptères mais pour les
radios il y a il est à de frais qui sont
remboursés aux états et donc pour cela
il ya quelques étapes par exemple l'inde
le bangladesh népal moi je dirais aussi
l'uruguay acquis qu'ils reçoivent
beaucoup d'argent en participant aux
internationales et les palais il envoie
il envoie des soldats ils sont tous les
gens quand ils arrivent il faut les
équiper ouais
mais ensuite bien entendu pour par
exemple les opérations de l'otan aussi
de le nord africaine même de nous
européennes où les gens font rouler les
opérations aussi qui sont menées à
drogue ça veut dire son
cadre institutionnel les financements
viennent d'autres d'autres sources
comment sais tu vois que source par
exemple
l'opération de l'union africaine qui se
déroule en ce moment en somalie là c'est
presque entièrement le nom européenne
qui paient pour les clés légende au fond
les street a de hyundai
rwanda et d'autres pays africains des
participants c'est l'équivalent d'un
proxy c'est une guerre par procuration
c'est l'équivalent d'un marcel
mercenariat mais là il faut vraiment
distingué parce que normalement le terme
mercenariat s'est toujours attaché à des
firmes privées
mais là c'est souvent avec gouvernement
qui encaisse l'argent d'autres
gouvernements alors si on veut parler
d'un marché c'est vraiment un marché
entre gouvernement et là par exemple en
somalie il a des pays riches
notamment l'union européenne qui veut
que la situation se tranquillisent
notamment parce que nous avons des
intérêts de
pour les le commerce il y a beaucoup de
navires qui passent par là
et mais pour l'europe et enfin soldats
européens très cher ici le public est
très critique et notamment par rapport à
la somalie puisqu'il y avait peut-être
me connaissez l'histoire de black hawk
down
où il y avait des américains était voilà
tu es et ensuite c'était un peu le
désastre à cete c'était vraiment dans le
public international et donc là il ya
une préférence du pays des soldats de
l'ouganda par exemple au lieu de
l'envoyer à la france est à l'opinion
publique coûte très cher c'est ça il
faut il faut que l'opinion publique
occidentale
on préserve ses soldats télévisuellement
c'est ça oui mais je crois il ya aussi à
des motifs économiques alors là
les salaires en disant son
suivant l'une européenne fait à peu près
1200 dollars par mois par soldat qui
représente quel volume total et
elle l'a fait pour le france était à
cent mille cinq cent mille 500 millions
d'euros que l'union européenne à payer
pour en 2000 être atteint plusieurs mois
en 2015 qu'est ce que vous pouvez me
dire de l'otan est ce que l'otan à une
politique prédatrice est ce que l'otan
n'est pas devenu l'ersatz de la
politique étrangère américaine face à la
russie la chine l'inde peut-être même
l'europe
est non non non je vous raconte on peut
de l'opération en libye en 2011 c'était
la fin je peux vous parler aussi de
l'opération en afghanistan isaf c'est
une opération gigantesque de l'otan est
mais je trouve l'opération en libye
c'est plus intéressant peut-être alors
du coup ce qu'il faut vraiment savoir
des interventions militaires toujours
en gros c'est une politique comme par
exemple une politique commerciale dans
le commerce on s'est toujours il ya des
gagnants et des perdants là aussi on va
libérer complètement le commerce de
l'agriculture en france il y aura des
gagnants peut-être des consommateurs
mais il ya sûrement aussi des perdants
avec hauteur ils sont en france par
rapport aux interventions militaires on
a toujours l'impression que une telle
division est davantage n'existe pas
parce que c'est la sécurité alors tout
le monde va en bénéficier mais en gros
pour les interventions de militaires il
est exactement la même division il ya
des gagnants et là des groupes
d'intérêts qui vont profiter plus il est
à d'autres qui vont perdre alors qui
sont ces gagnon de temps enfin ça peut
être bien sûr d des entreprises du
pétrole de l'uranium
entreprises de défense mais aussi
ensuite des organisations humanitaires
quelqu'un par exemple hic qui milite
dans une organisation afin qu'ils
s'intéressent pour le droits de l'homme
retire plus comment économistes diraient
plus de l'utilité que quelqu'un qui me
dit dans une récente de l'environnement
par exemple parce que là
quand on
est revenu en libye c'était quand même
aussi avec quelques raisons humanitaires
auxquelles on voulait on voulait sauver
les gens de benghazi
pour télé démocratie pour les petites
filles oui pour les petits fille et je
crois que c'était surtout
voilà on allait vraiment tort que que ça
a vraiment bladi bladi
sur le conflit libyen quand même là il
ya des zones d'ombré par rapport à
kadhafi et l'intervention de sarkozy en
libye s'était pas piloter à votre avis
oui et pour cela c'est alors pour
vraiment comprendre cette intervention
il faut regarder quels groupes
d'intérêts ont poussé pour cette
intervention et surtout en france il y à
un comme une tradition qu'il a toujours
un mélange entre groupes humanitaires je
dirais et ensuite groupe business ce
lèche défense mais les terres des
cantons bon quand on associer les deux
est-ce que ça crée une dialectique du
type bombardements humanitaires
intervention extérieure humanitaire
alors ça c'est une chose extrêmement
important parce qu en fait vu qu'il ya
deux groupes qui sont extrêmement
différents
mais quand même au moment où ils
poussent ensemble pour cette
intervention il collaborèrent il
collabore très très bien mais ensuite
une fois l'intervention effet les
objectifs divergent extrêmement
terme à des interventions est tellement
catastrophique par exemple en irak on
avait en gros trois groupes aux états
unis qui voulaient l'intervention en
irak
alors c'était l'intervention 2003 le
conservateur il avait les
néoconservateurs mais là aussi elles
avaient deux groupes à l'intérieur de
cette
île avait les gens qui voulaient joueurs
montrer de la face parce qu'il
considérait que toute cette époque ce
clint mêmes bush père
l'amérique était faible une aide et des
grandes idées est et des
néoconservateurs
css3 voir que des faiblesses et leurs
comptes voilà et donc il faut tu as
démontré la force américaine et
l'afghanistan ce n'était pas encore
suffisant alors pour eux le seul
objectif de l'intervention en direct
c'était démontré de la force et détruire
en deux semaines toute l'armée irakienne
parce que l'armée irakienne était quand
même encore une ennemie conciliables à
cet étage c'était pas des petits
talibans avec des avec tes dents qui
avec des arbres n'importe quoi un groupe
juste montré de la force il ya un autre
groupe qui voulait vraiment construire
de la démocratie tant que gros ça
c'était au tour de condoleeza rice voile
faut vite il faut vite voulait faire de
la démocratie comme de lestage il était
condoleeza rice était quelqu'un qui a
grandi intellectuellement pendant la fin
de la guerre froide et là il avait le
moment que
de la ça s'appelle
démocratique pis série alors si tous les
régimes autoritaires tombe on va tous
vivre en paix partout dans le monde
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la doctrine
de brienz qui qu'est ce que vous en
pensez quelle doctrine
interventionniste
mais l'interventionnisme pourra pour des
objectifs notamment de construire
démocratie
de ce qu'on nous en dit
j'ai pas l'impression en fait que toutes
les interventions étaient motivés comme
vous m'avez démontré que par des
intérêts d'humanitaires la question que
nous on se pose c'est vraiment il y a
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un plan vraiment
plus à long terme un plan stratégique à
30 ans de soi conquête soit de
déstabilisation quand on a vu la
ceinture méditerranéenne s'embraser avec
la tunisie l'egypte et que en egypte on
a retrouvé des gens américain avec le
parfait petit kit du révolutionnaire
c'est à dire du cash décédé de la
propagande écrit était de quoi imprimer
tout ça on se pose la question est ce
que ces gars là ne sont pas aussi
stimulé pour créer un contre-feu
économique en face de l'europe c'est à
dire empêcher l'europe de se projeter
économiquement sur ces nouveaux marchés
qui serait naturel par les états unis et
ensuite un isolationnisme américain on
peut le voir et c'est en train de se
retirer un peu partout parce que c'est
compliqué ils recentrent leur budget
militaire en europe le pentagone a
multiplié par quatre son budget
d'intervention pour l'année prochaine
pour contrer l'influencé de la russie
paraît-il donc la question réellement
qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que les
américains n'ont pas une stratégie en
deux temps c'est à dire mettre le feu
faire la politique de la terre brûlée en
face de chez nous et ensuite dire bon
vous débrouillez vous avez plus de mille
ans qui débarque chez vous c'est pas
bien grave la syrie l'irak l'afghanistan
c'est un vrai bourbier mais on va
laisser ça comme ça parce que bon ben on
sait pas comment faire puis toutes les
façons il y en un port tellement cher
est pendant tellement d'années que on a
des seins des interventions électoral à
respecter ou des échéances électorales à
respecter qu'est-ce que vous enfoncez
s'il n'y a pas de politique si on va
dire c'est pas si elle ment fait le
déstabilisation de tous ces pays
vous savez on a beaucoup parlé d'eux
de cette théorie
aussi par rapport en septembre alors
vous faites référence aux déclarations
de wesley clark le général wesley clark
enfin voilà partout dans l'internet
partout alors tes théories en pratique
pas ça on pratique les théories du
11-septembre pratique simplement le fait
que le général wesley clark a fait des
déclarations que vous êtes vous les avez
entendus on est on les affichera l'écran
on peut ce montage si le général wesley
clark qui était quand même si mes
souvenirs sont monde l'ancien chef
d'état major des troupes de l'otan en
europe duroux était aussi viré du pet à
gand voilà quelqu'un qui est juste se
promènent et est respectée est là bas
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui a été viré
qui n'est pas appréciée à bah c'est sûr
que s'il fait chuter des mémoires en
défense ils ont pas dû la presse et
souvent et donc ces mêmes c'est aussi
très doux table et s'il est rarement
beaucoup de accès à des gens qui
emporterait mans mais alors pour
reprendre à votre question il y a trois
mondes un type de demande qu'en gros à
washington.le gens comme moi mais aussi
à des gens qui travaillent en attente et
king kong qui joue avec le prix monte
c'est un monde
unipolaire et en gros le l'irak et les
néo conservateurs voulaient construire à
travers cette intervention ou prolongée
au moins le monde unipolaire ça veut
dire il ya juste un paul c'est le états
unis mais pour rester à le seul pôle au
monde il faut toujours démontré de la
force vous faites référence le bn a
cessé sa
exactement et l'idée ici c'est en gros
pourquoi
pourquoi il avait là la première guerre
mondiale c'était un monde multipolaire
il avait l'allemagne la russie la france
l'angleterre et sa et mais pour coller à
des pôles comme ça on peut pas créer un
équilibre c'est très difficile de créer
des déséquilibres fils marc lassus le
phare mais bon quand il est parti à tout
est explosif ensuite il ya le un monde
bipolaire pendant la seconde borne à la
car froide en effet dans un monde
bipolaire mais là aussi c'est plus
stable comme monde multipolaire mais ça
aussi les difficultés parce qu'on a
toujours
besoin de belles ending il faut toujours
garder l'autre et des deux côtés il se
crée des images très profonde de
d'ennemis et donc aux états unis la
préférence un des
certaines élites c'est le monde
unipolaire mais en même temps qu'ils
sont très conscients que c'est très
difficile et notamment en fait au lieu
de rétablir ou renforcer le monde
unipolaire à travers l'irak est aussi
l'afghanistan m l'intervention a
provoqué exactement le contraire parce
que les états unis n'a pas pu démontrer
la force en gros ils ont démontré la
faiblesse parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
capables de vraiment conquérir le pays
et voilà c'est encore le désastre là-bas
dans le proche orient donc en gros les
états unis maintenant ils ont adapté
l'image ouvre le dieu d'un futur
bipolaire mais pour le cesu ni et c'est
le grand contraire je trouve conversait
avec avec les européens et les deux
pôles c'est clairement le pacifique
alors surtout la chine et
les états unis et donc pour pour le sait
unis le grand où la grande question
c'est en fait que fait l'europe parce
que là il rentre la défense en général
mais surtout l'europe parce que elle
fera les états unis veulent bien entendu
que l'europe fait partie de du comte de
l'ouest alors si on a deux pôles le pôle
chine et le pôle états unis pour leur
pur pour l'europe évidemment si c'est
selon les désirs et l union fait partie
du conte étasuniens et dans tout
l'europe ici il faut toujours plus fort
et moi je trouve qu'il n'ya pas cette
réflexion mais il faut bien réfléchir si
on veut vraiment faire partir de 2,7
enfin de coalition alliance voilà mais à
quel à quel titre à titre non mais en
gros c'est
exactement le grand à salou com
c'est à une
une réplication et copie du monde
pendant la guerre froide
et que ça tous la même choses justes
l'année mais maintenant c'est la chine
et à la russie alors on a un jeu kg on a
quelques copains bien informé washington
qui reviennent des états unis que nous y
exactement la même chose c'est à dire
qu'il ya une mentalité de guerre froide
sous stéroïdes dans la génération des 40
55 ans c'est à dire la génération qui
étaient soit nos grands frères soient
n'opère plus jeunes pour certains
avec cette mentalité guerrière
comment ça se passe au niveau de
l'europe de la défense comment l'europe
va se positionner par rapport à ça est
ce que là on va suivre et quel est votre
avis sur ce qui se passe avec la russie
on voit la russie encerclé par la l'otan
physiquement parlant en cercle et vous
étudié toutes les positions de
géolocalisation des bases de l'otan
on sent que la russie un petit peu prise
entre le marteau et l'enclume et on voit
que la crimée que le bouclier
antimissile avant pologne ça se
rapproche et on voit la situation
vraiment ce tendre alors on a eu
quelques contacts avec les russes les
rues sont encore un petit peu serein
mais quand même dépôt des systèmes de
défense de la syrie jusqu'à l'arctique
comment ça va se terminer selon vous
il a toujours c'était une alternative au
monde qui est projetée par les
américains c'est le monde multipolaire
c'est toujours une option même si pour
les américains c'est vraiment c'est pas
vraiment mon désir ou même qu'ils
imaginent c'est enfin en réalité bien
sûr c'est toujours une alternative alors
que pour l'europe il faut au moins à un
niveau
intellectuel il faut se demander alors
peut-on tenir
le partenaire des etats-unis dans leur
lutte contre la chine petits-enfants où
elle n'était pas préférable de créer un
monde multipolaire et donc
créer un pôle européen
ou à
d'autres
alors on va essayer de se faire un
scénario un peu noir je vais vous
demander de réagir à ce scénario là je
rien préparé ça veut dire comme ça va
venir alors la situation économique sur
les marchés financiers se dégrade les
prix du pétrole dégringole le budget de
la russie s'effondrent les budgets des
producteurs de pétrole s'effondre les
flux migratoires tant économique que du
conflit s'accélère
ça déstabilise tout les tous les pays
basé sur les routes de flux migratoires
une balkanisation des politiques
européennes avec une augmentation
puissante ferme et profond de l'extrême
droite un repli identitaire est ce que
vous pensez que ça va être très
gouvernable tout ça au niveau européen
ça va être ingouvernable l'onu mais
enfin c'est votre cas
mais donc c'est exactement cette
question qu'il faut se poser alors parce
que si on en crée pas une europe défense
alors le monde futur est déjà fait c'est
soit une polaire ou bipolaires ses os et
donc mais peut-être c'est peut-être ce
et désirable moi j'ai pas une opinion
procédez vous avez une vision
anthropologique c'est à dire enfants et
moi j'ai fait en gt gt pas vivante 10
ans pendant quatre ans
pour moi c'est très difficile donc juste
à partir de la littérature de juger
comment c'était et c'est vraiment un
monde bipolaire est préférable à un
monde multipolaire pour moi
je sais pas pratiquement je sais pas
théorie moi j'aimais et les met
pratiquement je sais pas je trouve très
difficile même nous en tant qu'européen
on peut aussi dire quand on a des
avantages de monde unipolaire plutôt
parce que on est quand même des amis des
américains pour une menace pour nous
c'est plus facile de parler avec les
américains par exemple que avec chinois
je crois en france et on voit si on va
essaimer liens culturels et qu'ils ont
je dirais quand même plus proche
mais
moi je trouve européen au mois il faut
faire le choix
conscient il faut réfléchir parce que
sinon on va juste suivre les choix des
autres regardons comment réfléchir sans
une autonomie de pensée est ce que vous
pensez pas qu'il ya une projection de la
doctrine américaine au sein même de nos
élites c'est à dire qu'il ya vraiment
une grande partie américaine mind id est
ce que c'est pas compliqué de pouvoir
avoir cette autonomie de pensée à cause
de ça
non moi j'habite aux états unis mais
dans quoi presque huit ans et je crois
de l'autonomie
c'est à chacun de le prendre de le
saisir prendre il faut se battre pour le
pendre absolument pas je crois à passer
des temps partout allez ce qui se
passait dans la tête en tant qu'allemand
excusez moi en tant qu allemande qu'est
ce que vous pensez de la décision
d'angela merkel de prolonger les
sanctions contre la russie
vous savez l'allemagne
part à un temps
extrêmement intense en ce moment ça a
commencé avec avec plus ou moins la
russie mais aussi air et c'était en gros
je prends beaucoup au diplôme est
notamment à washington
et là c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est quand même encore un des centres
de pouvoir au monde et là le statut
d'epic est assez facilement
touchable c'est par exemple c'est très
facile d'avoir un rendez vous avec avec
le vice-président ça veut dire pour ces
pays
son pouvoir sa puissance à augmenter
là quand je parle aux diplomates
étrangers mais qu'ils ont un projecteur
ils me disent tous que pour l'allemagne
et sa énormément changé là ça fait
peut-être deux trois mois de trois ans
désolé
qu'on pour l'allemagne est vraiment
devenu un pays clé
à washington et c'était aussi parce
qu'il avait une croissance économique
l'allemagne encore en france et le grand
contraste avec la chance il ya une vraie
croissance économique en vrai boom
économique
mais en même temps bien entendu avec
avec la croissance économique il y à
aussi ensuite à une
voile à une prise de conscience
de
pourrait dire des responsabilités mais
aussi de vouloir
s'engager et vouloir entendre sa voix
dans nos relations attention vous parlez
d'entendre sa voix quand la nsf écoute
sangay merkel jusqu'au pro plus profond
de ses communications
les allemands ont perçu ça comment ils
se sont sentis violés par leur fameux
allié américain
elle et les américains ou la russie non
les américains ont écouté angela merkel
non je crois les américains il aime bien
vous avez écouté merkel parce qu'elle
est intéressant non mais l est pas
elle est pas là lieder flambeau dans
dont je re
ll est
responsable et en fait c'est pour ça que
la nsa douala écouter le connaissait la
nsa bien sûr à mais en gros disons les
amériques les américains apprécient
merkel beaucoup je les quitte à mende
par exemple là il ya quand même une
vraie menace que l'angleterre sorte de
mini robin le mot exit le breakbeat et
là le pont où le pays qui était encore
le plus proche au cesu ni dans
l'européenne c'est toujours l'angleterre
mais au cas où l'angleterre va sortir
moi je suis sûr que l'allemagne va
remplacer cette place qui a normalement
toujours
appartenu alors c'est une place mais
c'est aussi une place de cheval de troie
ensuite les américains ils ont seulement
aussi puissant qu'on nous les européens
sont faibles et uzi laisse
je vais vous poser encore deux dernières
questions la dernière sera donné un
concert d'une nouvelle génération sur
internet un conseil pour en durcir leur
esprit critique donc ça c'est votre
dernière question mais l'avant dernière
celle que je vous pose maintenant
en tant qu'universitaire
femmes c'est pas trop dur puis c'est dur
ouais c'est même si cela le d'ailleurs
que ce soit dur parce qu'on est à peu
près de la même génération
comment ça se fait que encore à notre
époque
ce soit
cette politique de primitifs
il faut être primitif pour ne pas
écouter ce qu'il a dans la tête d'une
femme
oui tout à fait et donc je peux juste à
dire que toutes les femmes puissent être
c'est très dur il faut lutter mais ça
vaut le coup quand même c'est beaucoup
absolument il faut il faut on a pas
d'autres options
mais en fait je crois la difficulté
enfin pour moi là
la plus grande c'était que
vous savez si un homme est prof par
exemple à un mot neige il y a beaucoup
de filles beaucoup de femmes que dirait
pouvoir mais c'est magnifique quel génie
fou
j'exagère il est énorme respect pour
une femme comme moi c'est un
cnt m'aider
et ça
ça me fait du mal qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour l'aider il faut moi je suis
pour une politique de discrimination
positive
parce que il faut créer des volumes à
n'importe quelle femme de la politique
et c'est une petite bonne femme c'est
très très bien pour moi sans gens comme
condoleezza rice comme madeleine
albright comme samantha pas haut comme
en bas la culture
est encore
trop connu un j'étais trop jeune
mais sont les femmes comme ça
moi je pourrais pas faire
c'est vraiment des leaders de sa livrée
alors nous on a côtoyé quelques femmes
de pouvoir on trouve qu'elles seront
pires que les hommes c'était encore plus
dur que les hommes
elles sont elles sont blindées et elles
ont oublié de cette sensibilité que nous
les hommes on a oublié peut-être est-ce
que vous vous enduire site c'est pas tel
point que vous en oubliez votre féminité
vous savez un
camp quand le sait la seule et ça
m'arrive souvent quand je suis la seule
femme autour d'une table
et je hais je dis quelque chose et
ensuite il y à un homme plus ou moins
volage peut-être un peu plus vieux qui
répète exactement la même chose que moi
j'ai dit et tout le monde applaudit le
mec et ignorent mon commentaire qui
était avant ça me montre qu'il ait
discrimination totale et qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire dans ce moment qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire si on est tous
avec un sourire
ça change rien
venez voir le sujet sur internet on va
vous protéger dans ce cas précis un
conseil pour les jeunes jeune génération
à l'autre peut-être et il faut vraiment
réfléchir dans quel monde on veut
habiter parce que là c'est très facile
aux etats-unis au mois il ya une telle
conscience qu'ils ont le leader au monde
que je tairai pas tout le monde mais on
mois
l'élite refléchit au futur moi je trouve
ici c'est toujours mailing blue
et
ça c'est pas une option
énorme que merci merci à vous
[Musique]
parent
là
[Musique]